the writer and director of obsidia
boys oh my goodness amazing it's great
like it's little surreal right now you
know
oh my goodness okay I've no yeah like
boys there you know I think like was
amazing all the screenwriters here I
think have such unique and individual
voices and as we get an independent
cinema you know my voice is my voice
that's what separates you know and I go
like everyone I go like we're amazing me
the film's here I go there also unique
and really like someone's widget which
is perhaps what you don't get maybe with
studio films so much for it you know
it's almost by committee independent
films is very much someone's boys
you know for me as a writer it's been a
long shot
anything like some people i have blown
away by the Mariners were like totally
okay you know a writer for me was like
the hardest thing in the world to get
writers you know I think because like
you're just so exposed you know device
some people i right you know I try to
act up there's really from my heart you
know and you feel very very exposed like
your hearts on you guys out there you
know it's very vulnerable so it's like
to me it's yeah definitely like a lot of
years of just writing and struggling and
actually being a writer in that sense
there sugar never mind the career that
secondary to me that means I guess
there's like Jesus sidelines they serve
go the real thing is writing something
that's their issue you know writing
something something I mean really young
I did everything you know like all kinds
of wasting whoever but then I taught
yoga for years so I used every Open
School in partial own hand yeah I always
go like i like i love t0 so I mean you
know it might be a survival job in some
ways
hahaha
project nominee game
like I love somebody I really do love so
many films here um probably those the
access from the gift shop you know
because i love mr. brainwash Banksy's
all right for mr. brainwash is also i
love Terry door shut ya hang out with
him baby also yeah yeah
thank you
you